foreign
We are continuing our discussion about
multi-computation and programming around
multi-computation
and I think Nick has let's see do I need
to I run this this initialization cell
here
yep
so this is just basically
a few new properties
and options that they added to the multi
object uh Nick what's this
uh
I've never seen that before
what version are you using I'm still
grinding all my code on 13.1
yeah this one
all right let me try quoting yeah
okay
I want to take a little bit
from the top here of um let's just make
sure this works
oh
what the heck is this
oh is it working maybe just to
question a question or he message you
something
it's still loads so
well let's try it
yeah just the old version
yeah
well
oh dear I wish we tried this
I mean I don't understand it can I do
pack of the uninstall of this
yeah let's try this I also reapolient
just in case what is this it says it
isn't found so fine you say
multi-consultation or something or from
slash you have to specify the name
Wolfram slash multiplication not the
link
in a string
yeah
okay
now let's try installing this
okay what is an uh where what is this
is
why don't we not use the short URL just
give me the full URL or can you try the
actual name the way you uninstalled it
well here I've got I've got this
you already went past the install line
yeah oh the same link
installed right you can try the same
string to install it from the repository
this one here
no you mean I mean who from swash multi
competition just install it with the
name not the link
well what's going on it's definitely
there well how do I know what packet
sites I'm looking at
talk about sites open close
is that the right place
there's the two default ones
well what the heck's going on I mean I
can find it here
or I don't know what what happens if I
just try and install
oh I see it's got to be the packlet
ah sigh come on we should be able to
deal with this
is verify packlet to get more
information
okay Nick are you are you figuring out a
solution or are we stuck here
and why does it say verified packlet
function if it doesn't exist why does it
say that here
Tracy that's for you to track down that
that shouldn't say that if the function
doesn't exist
I've noted it okay
okay Nick what do we do here we give up
on me me demoing stuff and you have to
do it on your machine
I'm not happy with that oh my machine
also probably magic for some reason I
can't even upload the packlet again
maybe it's something actually
in the cloud
well okay so
Tracy could you try and reach out to
whoever is relevant to
figure out if there's something maybe
Todd or somebody
um can do okay
uh
all right but let's take a look then
I don't understand that so
let me just review and particularly
since Jonathan is here and hasn't seen a
lot of this stuff I just want to review
kind of what the basic design is
and then we're going to be let me just
look at your
um
the stuff you sent pre-evaluated okay
so
let me just review so basically the idea
is
this is what's this function hypergraph
multi I don't think we have a bunch of
different functions like that
this is the the one that creates
multi-object compiling everything to
hypographs
I see
so
um and by compiling everything how does
it compile a general expression thing to
hypergraphs
you just compile it you basically tweet
the links the first element or the first
vertex and each hyper is just a link to
every
next sub expression
so if you have a three with children
then your hyper which would
contain as much links as their children
also in addition to the payload and its
own link
mm-hmm so that's how it can it can
compile the arbitrary
and therefore it can compile an
arbitrary expression in the same way
okay but so
but it doesn't have the semantics of the
of it is just doing
a structural compilation is that correct
yeah sure because as soon as you
evaluate the right hand side to lose
all the causal information it would be
hard to retrieve it from there
so the main thing you're doing with this
hypographic compilation is
in a hypergraph causality is very well
defined by do you you know this hyper
Edge is eaten you know is destroyed here
create you know Etc et cetera et cetera
you're using this as a way to make sure
to keep track of causal information is
that correct yeah
I'm wondering if Jonathan has any
particular comment on that
um
was there a question I don't know I mean
that well no the the point is for
General objects
okay
it isn't necessarily defined and this is
an issue that that you had in some of
your multi-way X
functions of just what is the you know
what is the thing that is the element
whose causal information will be tracked
so to speak well I mean okay first of
all one has to be very clear on what one
means by causal information right there
are many different Notions of causality
that you can equip a graphic writing
system with which are which are more or
less expressive we tended to use I mean
sorry I should say this in the past
tense we did tend to use a very
particular one in the context of the
physics project
um but there's you know there are that
has a bunch of limitations as we've
discussed like the fact that you know an
event that sort of just touches an edge
but doesn't actually manipulate it will
still show up as being kind of causally
related to other events that make use of
that edge
um
so I mean what exactly do we mean by
causality here well I know that's what
that's why I was asking you to join the
conversation here because because what
Nick is doing is he is transforming any
thing that is being you know that is
being consumed into hypographs at which
point he then has a well-defined
definition of causality you know
so Nick what what what is the definition
what is your definition of causality for
hypographs well it's the same as the
woofer model causality definition okay
actually it's just using hyper edges
right right so if if the you know if the
output for one event makes use of hyper
edges that were producing the output of
another event
yep okay right even if they were
identity transformations
yes or identity up to
isomorphism or whatever and in
particular also doesn't encode the the
kind of the Dual notion of of you know
inhibit inhibition causality
which you invented right Jonathan is
that true or is that
well you know no idea is truly new right
I mean the these things are
um similar Notions have been discussed
in the context of things like Petri Nets
and sigma Nets and things
um I don't think it had been discussed
in the context of arbitrary rewriting
systems before okay but just to review
that okay what you mean by that is
this is an edge which says instead of an
edge which enables something to happen
by virtue of yes this function has its
input ready you're saying this
inhibitory Edge says if this is produced
this function cannot happen
right
right
which is something Nick is certainly not
you know now in the context of
hypergraphs is it obvious how to do that
is that obvious I mean you know that
would be
like imagine I would create some
additional options for the music place
when instead of replacing tuples and
subsets having rules on those they also
take elements that inhibit stuff
right that's essentially an accept or is
it something different
well yeah it can be
parameterized by except but maybe in a
different way the only point that the
rule or its output would be would have a
key that this particular hyper age was
inhibition and high bridge and I can use
this information to create in my
causal graphs and events there right but
you're saying that the event that takes
place
the thing that we're assuming that
you're assuming in the hypograph world
is that events pick up a subset you know
you've got a big vat of hyper edges and
an event picks up some subset some Tuple
of hyper edges and transforms them into
some other Tuple of high bridges
so what you're saying is there can be a
poisonous thing in the vat
which
how exactly would that work where
there's a hyper Edge
how would that work sorry I don't quite
understand how that inhibition thing
works in that context
well if you have an element with literal
except
in your list of left-hand side High
pages right
since you can't create an event but you
in usual sense but in this case you
actually create one
a special kind of event and maybe with
some dummy output
okay but Jonathan do you have a
different way of understanding what you
know in the vat of hyper edges what an
inhibitory hyper Edge so I mean that
could work but it places the burden on
the user right to
um to be able to specify that you know
you could easily specify an inconsistent
version of that
you mean with inhibition and
non-inhibition
yeah
okay well what's a different way the
reason for choosing I mean the reason
okay Nick choosing this the sort of
physics project notion of causality is a
very sensible decision because it's the
it's the version of causality that's
relatively easy to determine
um there's a well-defined finite
deterministic algorithm that could
determine whether uh you know where the
two events are culturally related with
something like inhibition there is no
reliable General procedure for doing it
right you have to kind of because you
know okay for instance take a an obvious
example would be
um or an example where the right answer
is obvious so uh suppose you have a
graphy right an ordinary graph rewriting
system for undirected graphs uh where
you you know there are two rewrite rules
one of which is polarity preserving
and the other of which operates on some
non-planar tangle
then
if you you know if you start with an if
you start an initial condition with you
know with with a single non-planar
tangle and then that gets destroyed by
some application of either of the two
rewrites then obviously the one that
acts on the non-planar tangle can never
be applied
yes
um but to determine that algorithmically
is essentially a problem of automated
theorem proving over rewriting systems
which is hard to do
um yeah so you you so you can definitely
imagine having a user-specified kind of
inhibition function in the same way that
we have user-specified decomposition
functions or something and place the
burden on the person defining the
multi-way system
that's what we have to do otherwise it's
undecidable basically I mean okay but
but beyond the the causalities and
decide all right the
the list of events that you can produce
is decidable oh absolutely yeah well the
list of events you can produce at any
time step is pretty yeah yeah it's the
problem with the division because with
an inventory causality is that in
general it's a statement about you know
infinite time limits
my question is this okay so absent the
inhabitory thing which is interesting
but I think uh there's still a herring
far away I I was only bringing that up
in the context that they're you know
even in graph rewriting there are many
Notions of causality people have
developed right the the physics project
one is is just one of the more
straightforward ones
good
I mean you know because it's like
there's many Notions of girlfriend
writing which include very obscure
things that uh you know I just don't
think or or you know Dimension
estimation and so on there are lots of
you know I think
right I think what we need you know the
goal here
just let's let's zoom out for a second
you know
part of the point here is in Wolfram
language in general we have single way
you know we have a single way rewriting
system with a fairly arbitrary
collection of choices that were made
many many years ago which has worked
really well
our goal is to generalize that to the
multi-computational case
and to understand how you think about
sort of language design in the
multi-computational case with the idea
that that will also be relevant in
modeling Etc et cetera et cetera so
the fact that we are making a somewhat
arbitrary Choice a simple but arbitrary
choice I think that's inevitable I think
we have to make a choice I mean we you
know I'd just like to make sure we look
around and see is there another choice
we could be making that would be you
know would be better
and the big thing that concerns me is
that you know the compilation to
hypergraphs is just a very different
thing than we've ever thought about in
the context of you know wolfen language
or anything like it
you know the compilation to hypergraphs
is a kind of it's a in a sense it's a
new idea in terms of of um you know what
we're saying is pre-structured
expressions are not clear enough in
terms of their causal structure
for us to use those as the base for what
we're doing if we're going to have
causal information is that a fair
statement
I mean could we have could this all be
mapped on to transmissions on trees or
is it fundamentally not able to does
that have all of this weird uh you know
tree-like separation loopback link you
know thingies that happen where it isn't
clear how you do the causality
Nick
wow
well this compilation is pretty
straightforward if you actually think
when each of the sub expression in a
tree has its own address
so if you
have a very low level representation of
a tree
and you replace part of it you have a
pretty straightforward definition what
actually happened and where in memory
right and that's what those links are
representing so you can see what we've
been destroyed and what was created as
just some modification of memory right
okay so let me just understand so Ian
for example if you were to take the
three data structure and we were to say
can we turn that tree data structure
what will be involved then maybe Nick
already has things like this I mean just
the very straightforward thing I've got
you know a random tree
okay there's a random tree
turn this into a hypergraph what do I do
can we look at like a much smaller
tree
I
sure I don't yet understand myself what
this compilation of hypergraph in diaper
graphs looks like
okay Nick minimal case
what
do you have functions
run but two links hypergraph just run it
all this
I mean do we think it
okay do we think it's actually going to
work or
well old version is the same as the new
one if you just had a problem
okay
so can we draw this as a tree
um what is this to make this can you
explain like what do these links mean
so the first element is just to
basically hyper Rich index so it's not
important if we had some actual address
of each of those
it would be the same then it's a payload
and every subsequent
vertex is just a link to another average
so just a linked thing
what it's doing is
in our language found expression what's
that what does this do if the head is a
compound expression like replace G with
G of one
which will do the construct field
I think the way to think about this is
as follows
in this tree you know
in standard woven language we are
absolutely hiding the fact that there is
a pointer
in the middle of this this is really F
of you know this is saying f is applied
to this pointer and that pointer which
I'm not going to type the same is G of x
so so one question is is this
to use an obscure way of saying it is
this is this running share so I mean is
it actually doing the sub tree
isomorphism stuff to you know
to make this meaningful
like we're all instances of G of X will
be the same uh hyper Edge that's a good
question what's the answer Nick
I think I understood the question okay
let me let me show you we can make the
we can make a version of this okay so if
I say
G of x g of x
oh you're just going to point to the
same thing no no no no no no no what
Christopher is asking is those two G of
x's could be the same
right those are those G of x's could
actually be the same piece of memory
or not as the case may be I mean that is
not defined in you know this question
here let me just um
but it's sort of important because I
assume that the way that you do uh you
know when you apply a transformation you
get a new expression back that you then
have to do basically the the it's
essentially the sub tree isomorphism
stuff to say where does uh
you know does does the G of X and the
input expression appear somewhere in the
output expression but that question is
only meaningful if all the G of X is in
the input expression are you know
considered the same
no wait a second Christopher there are
two different cases here
okay this is where this is where the
giant can of worms okay
if if this was a piece of space so to
speak is it in fact the same piece of
space because they're both G of X right
and then the question is over time but
the point is I'm saying these are
related things because I'm assuming
maybe there's a different scheme but I'm
assuming that the way that you associate
G of x from you know
from step one with G of X at step two is
that you you do sort of you look oh does
g of X appear in step two and if it does
then you sort of say this is the same G
of X but if you had multiple G of x's in
the input at step one then it's not
really meaningful to say well which G of
X turned into the geodes indeed what
Nick is doing is he's he's saying these
G of x's are really different
here this one is it involves links two
and three this one involves links four
and five
so the fact that those things are both
called G of X is irrelevant to neck he's
using that positional that position in
the original expression to determine
what their sort of uh um what their
hypergraph addresses are
right Nick
right in this case yes but I I can
imagine they can share the piece of
hyper rich
piece of memory then just all the
replacement of the on those hyper graphs
should take this into account well I
understand that but so we don't have a
notation I mean right now if you say G
of x g of X I mean it is deeply not
something we're talking about whether
you know those two sevens probably a
shared those G of x's are not shared the
X's are shared
right because they both point to the
symbol table they point to a common
place in the symbol table but the G of
x's those are different pieces of memory
and so your you know
when do you run share yeah right when
are things
different and this is like you know in
our in our discussion of eems it's like
are these the same aim are they
different Eames
these things and I think Nick is
assuming that the structure of the
expression defines the sort of emac
structure and that they're different
which is fine but we may need a notation
to say these things should be treated as
the same
foreign
in fact I've been showing this with my
lazy expression remember when I can
create one laser expression and if I use
it twice in the next one it's gonna
share the same link which is which is
yes but that's horrifying in various
ways I mean in other words look are
things you know are things Auto shared
or not
and if they are Auto shared
you know over what what is the scope of
the auto sharing
that's what I'm saying I mean in other
words
if the thing and that relates again to
these questions that come up in the
physics project about causal edges
joining things at different time steps
and all kinds of funky stuff
I mean I put an example in check can can
we see what the output is
it
feel like this
this structure is ambiguous
well it's not clear construct refers to
a literal symbol in the expression
or when you're just using it to denote
I I feel like you're using two different
expression tree structures depending on
whether the head is atomic or not
I
oh yeah I can see if all the heads are
Atomic and you just say F links to G
links to X and Y
you're saying I can spoof this thing by
basically giving something which is
which where I'm going to create a
construct
yeah it's like writing the expression as
if it used a literal construct
yeah I bet you're right I bet you're
right I think the maybe the right thing
to do would be to just always use this
which and instead the out of 17
as opposed to like out of 13.
well that's not going to work it's going
to be too messy I mean I think the more
plausible thing to do is to have
something where instead of using
construct to deal with this case here
there is some new token that represents
a you know a sub value you know a
headdress type thing
I I still understand that reconstruction
always reconstruct the original
expression that's the only requirement
you follow the links and reconstruct the
original tree just should reproduce the
same one
and then other times you link the whole
expression To The Head and the arguments
which are two different things
my suspicion but I I don't think this is
a point I mean I I get this
okay my suspicion is that you really
need something which is you know look
construct
could perfectly well take this
presumably
and do that
well actually yeah I don't see what's
wrong with that
I think the only difference is like an
out of 13 F is linked to G
right oh yeah yeah yes
but in out of 17 F of one is not linked
to G in any way
it's the outer construct that's linked
to them
the six yeah
well why is that a problem you see the f
is now f is now a leaf
it never gets linked to anything you
have three comma f
I see
well I I don't completely understand
whether that's a problem I mean Nick is
making the statement if you can
reconstruct the expression from the
hypergraph then you're good
yeah and the only difference is a
construct version requires evaluation
yeah I suspect Ian is right that there's
something a bit fishy here I'm not sure
this is that that's not that's not drive
let's pin this as an issue yeah I think
I get the thing now so I think my
question's been answered thanks okay but
so the model that we're using is
see I the thing is okay
and and what's the relationship between
okay so in Ian's Trace graph okay what's
a good minimal example of tracegroff
um
what's a good function to put in here
times three
that's not very good
what I am
well whatever this is doing
that seems better
okay
my question here is
one of our goals is to make this
multi-way
and my question is is that doable with
Expressions here or do we have to
compile them to hypographs in which case
we've got a whole different level of
complexity in these things here
comments from from Nick and Ian
well everyone
if every kind of evaluation will just
equation
graph replacement
or expression replacement then
then it can be possible but it's not the
only kind of evolution that's there
that's where that's in this picture
in general
as soon as you
step away from just rewriting
you kind of toast as soon as you want to
run some kernel thing
that's called in a library and so on
it's easy when you're just regretting
stuff
no I I know I know I know so I mean but
look
what do you mean so you're saying if
you're just rewriting you could as well
use hypergraphs or expect or tree
expressions
is that correct is that what you're
saying but you're saying
what are you saying can you clarify
yeah it doesn't matter what kind of
object you're operation you just
typograph only provides a more
convenient causal information or if you
actually do it in a memory if you record
the access to memory then you can
recover some causality from there but
there's not really
difference I have a question in the
hypergraph compilation does it become
easy in practice to do distributed
computation on those things is that
plausible or is that absolutely hopeless
it's just when you say distribute
computations and it doesn't listen I
mean you put it in different processes
you you're
I think it's difficult because you're
using a subset type thing right where
you're you're taking this whole vat of
hyper edges and you're trying to find
you know two that you can pair together
and rewrite
it doesn't sound like a very
distributable kind of operation
right it's not something where you can
say I'll take this block of hyper edges
and run them on One processor another
block and run it on another processor
am I right
well right well well it depends maybe
you have some way of
uh matching a tuple or subset in
parallel you can just run one thread
solution for first element another one
for a second
maybe maybe but I mean they're still
going to have to have shared memory
it's not the case that I mean if we have
a list for example a standard array type
list
and we're doing an operational or you
know the same operation mapping across
that list
all those different list elements could
be in different processes with different
memory and we can be operating on them
separately whereas if we compile that
you know if we say you know
whatever it is
what was it called hypergraphed to Links
okay
you know if we do this and we say one
two three four well actually let's do
ABCD
actually I'm curious what happens if I
say one two three four in your code
how does it know what's what
the bullet is just the second element so
just distinguished by position
well it's a link does that always work
why not yeah
so links are always at the beginning and
end and payloads are in the middle
the second one element is no they're not
they're not the second element look
the second element
because you can have more than one
outgoing link
what about that
oh yeah well there's the second element
the first is the link of the hyper agent
everything
else is linking to another link into
another hyper ages
okay
but okay fine
um
let's see where we're going with this I
was just making the point that the ABCD
is easy to parallelize it is not obvious
to me that without sort of complicated
graph analysis that the hyper the you
know hypergraph
version of this is similarly has any
hope of parallelization
without significant analysis
just making the point okay so can we go
on and
you know I think it should be possible
to convert any dag into a hypergraph
the same way that you're doing this with
Expressions yeah you can even use a
graph run
a little graph would that already work
yeah
like do linked typograph of how do I
make a die random random graph directed
edges
goes to true
oh does it work on any graph
I think so
okay now what do I do
what do I say here the same thing to
link typograph to this thing
percent
[Music]
that's great
okay so you should be able to feed in
the output of in principle feed in the
output of Trace graph into this
and get the causal information
is that right
I'm not sure how he scraps a bag
well because the information comes when
you actually are writing it you're not
rewriting the trace graph
right it's like the edges in the trace
graph aren't necessarily rewriting rules
they're like subsidiary evaluations I
know and that's where it's going to get
really complicated represent links
right okay let's
okay can we go back to the original
thing
um
uh Nick I mean I just want to see your
original multi-way
okay how do I do a basic multi-way my
favorite numerical multi-way system
remind me how to do it in your framework
we'll just give it to
you soon what function the multi-way
object
okay then what do I say
at least the rules and initial condition
okay so the rules are
supposed to something X plus one
do I do this
yeah and X goes to
timelines
didn't just ask for property
okay so that's a multi-way object of of
unknown
you know it's it's a lazy multi-way
object right
yeah it just stores the rules it already
compiled them to the hypergraph rules
okay all right fine so now
in here how do I okay so let's make say
I want to make the State score for this
you just ask the state's graph property
and give it a number of steps
but this is still quite slow is that a
true statement
yeah it is unbelievably slow here
what can we do to make it faster
well this is just this is ridiculous
is this real I mean is this What's
Happening Here is this broken
I'm not sure
seems to be uninterruptedly slow
okay but that should work now it can you
also make a causal graph from this
oh for goodness sake I think it crashed
so what do I do here I say
do I have to run something here I have
to say this does the install doesn't
still doesn't work
let's try it
I still have
we're all issues I can't upload the
packlet for some reason anymore so so
Tracy did you track that down
I emailed Todd I haven't heard back from
him yet
we need to actually find the answer
and if necessary ask
um
I mean is that is the packlet repository
up we could ask Conor as well he might
know
I'll find out
okay we kind of need an actual answer
okay so this is just saying can't get
this thing so how do I get how do I
re-enable this
well if you already removed the packet
then there's no way
okay so
really I'm debugging this okay
what anybody know that let's get Todd
here please
come on
I'll let him know
or Connor
okay what what's the uh URL for the
packlet Repository
for this particular bucket in general no
in general I'm trying to understand
whether the whether the packlet I mean
you you deployed it to the packet
repository correct
yeah I'm sure it tested it prior to this
meeting
at home this is
this is my public call this is the
market Repository
okay so here will your packlet show up
on this
should be
it was there
well it's not here
but what's the name of the pilot
hold on can you I don't know why it's
not there but the link
right so it's not there
so that's why it's not working because
it's just not there
okay so do you have a privately deployed
version of this password could you
deploy it and then can you deploy it
privately
then I can load it from that
well I'm trying that's what that's what
they've been it's not working yeah
well this is no good
hi okay is the packet repository just
down or dead
I mean not as far as I know I haven't
heard anything so what we're trying to
debug something where really this isn't
supposed to be a meeting about something
completely different
Nick has a packlet which apparently
I mean ah
um so there is a bug that's going to be
fixed very soon uh with the packlet site
file it's delayed updating around the
time you know within a couple hours
after a packlet is published
so is this published in the last few
hours or sometime today yeah yeah wrap
that in resource function so you have
packet install of resource function of
the uh resource function sorry sorry
resource object I'm sorry
of this
uh
actually I was looking at the subsequent
command but
well what should I be doing is this is
this the right thing oh look at that
what do you know
well now let me try running this
miraculous okay wait did you did you
restart the kernel though because
sometimes running get twice breaks
things
I didn't restart it do you think I need
to well I should it shouldn't break
things
oh yeah yeah okay
and let's see what this other thing
works over here
maybe try for the fewer steps I'm still
not sure what that's crazy it's doing
something
weird oh this is on on oh
it's not merging at all yeah yeah
that's the point of my properties it's
not merging by default but that's well
that's crazy we can't I mean you know
we've we've used statescraft for the
last three years to mean a merged
statescraft so we can't change that
thank you for your help I think we got
we got what we needed from you you're
welcome I'll note though that packlet
install command of the raw I think you
have in your other notebook of the
string you'll want to wrap that in
resource function too if you use it
um yeah you should be good to go all
right thanks
okay so what what do I do if I do
duplicate in
State canonical function goes to
automatic
okay so just so I understand what that
does is it takes any group so if those
were hyper graphs but okay how do I get
rid of all that crud
that's the next step in the agenda
usually when you get
the graph after duplication you wanna
count the multiplicities so we made a w
of r that makes a simple graph and
assigns weights look this is crazy this
is way too slow it's just not useful I
mean it it's got to be faster
right it's completely unusable to do
this
I mean it's amusing but it's not useful
right okay so
I'm sorry so the point of this place to
do canonical function is if they were
hypographs you were determining which of
the various
isomorphic ins you know presentations of
that hydrograph you're going to use is
that correct
Yeah Yeah by default is just hyperageous
when you do it automatic now it converts
them to
some canonical version of it no no no no
I'm trying to understand if if this is a
hypograph rewriting multi-way system
okay
my understanding what we've had before
which are changing is we've had a state
equivalence function
right
which determines whether so Jonathan
there's a question for you
you know with a state equivalence
function it says these two states are
equivalent but which one does it
actually use in making the multi-way
graph well quite I mean State
equivalence functions looking back were
a bad idea that's the I I I like this I
like the canonicalization approach
um because yeah exactly as you say in
situations where equivalence is
non-trivial like for hypographs we
essentially had to make an arbitrary
decision
um so in fact when when multi-way system
handles the Wolfram model case the state
equivalence is separate from the
canonicalization which is kind of stupid
and that you know the canonicalization
just uses an inbuilt hypergraph
canonicalizer
okay fine all right well I agree it
seems I um this is a much better
solution
okay
so
I the name probably is not optimal I
think it should be probably State
commercialization function I would have
thought Nick
well maybe
yeah argue for this name
it's just shorter no that's not a good
argument because the problem is you
don't know what it's doing
yeah
also it's not the function that's
canonical
right nautical function makes it sound
like it is yeah okay
it's already a little bit yes maybe you
could have canonical State functions the
function that gives you the canonical
state
yes that's better
but
again
you don't know how it parenthesizes
right no I know I think the
canonicalization is is more clear right
okay so now let's understand the event
canonicalization function so how do I
indicate this how do I show the events
here as a you know the bipartite type
graph with the events shown
connect
it's a evolution
or the same as multiway system Evolution
causal graph
right
but now notice that
with these numbers
in the past it wasn't very well defined
what the causal dependence story was
so have you now clarified that I mean as
is what you're doing now clarifying that
yeah it should it now well the only
difference you don't actually evaluate
the right hand side it's it's always
structural
I I'm thinking of some kind of property
but that evaluated but you're gonna lose
all the cause of information so you
don't actually multiply by two add one
okay so let's watch this because we're
going to see this right here
right can I can I put um graph graph
features in here and I put graph yeah
yeah you can
okay okay so what we're seeing here is
there's an event
that's very weird looking
this says
what the heck is this really doing
this is saying
explain this this thing to me here one
two plus one the same kind of format as
the string
Mutual system freelance is using you
have one that was an input on the top
I see I see I see I see this already had
the plus one
you know I see that was no go ahead go
ahead
well the states because you use the
state canonical function
evaluated the two right so
maybe it's still kind of
I don't understand this I don't
understand we've got a two here why are
we still seeing the one up here in that
event
I'm gonna show maybe a related also
converted in the vertex shape function
but the actual state is also
some kind of Plus
on your left branch and times on the
right branch
what I mean I don't understand this
state to get from this one to this two I
mean this seems completely wrong I mean
this this should say here one plus one
or two times one right yeah I agree it
should say that and it's actually
underneath
if you would like ask for vertex list or
something I'm pretty sure that it's
going to be a hyper graph that
corresponds to this expression like one
plus one it's just times doing something
weird so it's a bug okay fine
so
okay so this is the most minimal on
uncanonicalized version of things right
we didn't canogalize anything here now
if we say event canonicalization
function here
that didn't change anything for this
perhaps it just doesn't change anything
in this case no but maybe I think it did
there's still at least two events that
have not just now oh yeah yeah right
there is this one here right merged
okay so what happened there so that
happened that merged because
well because you because those events
are the same
those events are both one goes to two
events
even though they're not really both one
goes to two one is one goes to one plus
one and the other guy is one goes to two
times one
yeah I think it's a little the default
canonical equivalents it only considers
local thing so if it writes the one
that's the actual
event sorry what is the yellow box
showing is the global rendering of this
event but the event is local in a way
that it only acts in some subset of
hyperages or sub-expressions
yes but then it's canonicalized when
okay so here this is telling us this
destroyed and created is based on
the
what those are the ends basically is
that right those are the the elements of
the hyper edges correct yeah the links
specifically the first elements in this
particular right but the in the physics
context those links will be atoms of
space
correct those link names are atoms of
space
or in what the more General case atoms
of existence or Eames
right so what this is saying is uh
so this thing here is saying that event
destroyed eem2
how could it create into I thought these
things were only were one single use
object so no if you
it will almost
I think it's always going to create this
recreate the same one because there is
no point to destroying it completely you
can if you
can see if you look at it as a memory
you can put in the same address this sub
expression again
right the same aim to the same place
so if you destroy why isn't that aim
just outright destroyed
I don't understand I I thought in terms
of the hypograph wasn't it the case that
you destroyed the destroyed is like the
outgoing link
and the created is the incoming link is
that right no it's all the way around
destroyed is the incoming link created
is
like can we do the minimal case Nick
please
what is the minimal case of this
uh
well something with strings Maybe
specifically just take the same string
system on your in from the agenda
notebook
and maybe ask for
Justice
One Step choreograph or something
ever missing
M there in the beginning
with your object
what the heck is that
and her two events they're not closely
connected to each other
you can include an initial and maybe to
be clear I'm not sure what event include
initial event goes to true
okay so that's the big bang
from nothing we created AI
and
I don't understand I'm sorry I don't
understand why I think what's going on
that you don't see how the AAA itself is
represented
as tokens
yeah
and I mean so if you say two linked
typograph
of quotes a a
it looks like that
okay
I think you're gonna have a two tips for
the states
as a hypergraphs okay fine let's look at
that but I don't understand I don't
understand why didn't it destroy the
zero thing there so which one Evolution
causal graph well yeah it did destroy it
actually in this case it didn't really
create it oh yeah I don't have tooltips
I don't have tool tips for the multi for
the for the um hypergraphs here
okay I don't know
okay so let's take a look at I simply
don't understand this thing here so
right but you see in out of 19 there's
the two in both of those tokens yeah
it's because I changed the how the
String's been replaced can you add
method Goes To None to the mutual object
so that it actually uses
hypergraphs for like for Strings
not not for the graph but the actual
object when it when it creates in one
after the initial conditions method goes
to none
so now the two tip May
it's not it's not right
okay I don't understand this I don't
understand why
looking at this here okay it destroys
the two
because it's using the rule what is it
doing here what is it doing
well destroys the one hybridges makes
two hypers no no no that two index there
that it says it's destroying is the same
eem index as there is that correct
yeah the same
okay so what is it maybe with a
different payload
I don't know but the two is the same two
right yes okay so this event is doing
something to this State this state is
182 to a0 correct
that statement No it's pink it's two and
three because if you look at the initial
event
it creates two and three
okay okay so this is one A2 to A3
correct is this is this yes yes okay all
right so then okay I do not understand
this I don't understand
foreign
destroyed the
link number two and because free is
already taken it creates a link number
four it's a new one yeah I know but why
is it recreating link two
because it can there's no reason to but
not to use it absolutely no reason not
to reason I I don't agree with you I
think it's super confusing I think the
causality is super confused if you reuse
it
especially when you just if you want
uh somehow explore what actual event did
if you always have created different
links from the Destroyer you'll never
know
okay what is the causal relation between
the incoming thing
what I was understanding is that the
fact that I think the fact you're
reusing that name it is a different Eve
is it not or am I confused
it's the same link so it's a same same
as a link but it can change the payload
so payload changes is the second element
of Heritage who else understands what's
going on I must I must say that I've
never fully understood or even agreed
with the notion that atoms of space can
be destroyed or that that aims can be
destroyed I mean it seems as though you
will have some it could be some it could
be some computation it could be a
multi-way structure okay you're making
use of certain games okay this structure
has some you know has some some span
within the overall rouliad let's say and
it can it can capture an aim we could
say it could jettison but I don't see
how the computation itself has the power
to bring eems into the rouliad OR all
right so maybe the wording is wrong here
yes it shouldn't say correct destroyed
it should say consumed
I like to think of them I mean the Eames
are there I like to think of them as
being captured and let go I mean I said
jettison but that's okay that word's
probably not going to be oh they still
can be destroyed if your right hand side
is shorter than the left hand side that
even going to be destroyed completely
well what does it mean destroy a local a
local view you could say kind of
informally local to whatever multi-way
system that you're examining as kind of
a somewhat
semi-closed system I guess you could say
it's destroyed taking a structural view
of the rouliad they're definitely
they're definitely not destroyed
they're they're just not being used in
this particular multi-computation and
the creation that the creation of eems
is a is a complicated thing that
ultimately involves hyper computation
and the hierarchy of different wooly ads
so it's definitely not creating
well once they're there they're there
they're not getting destroyed by by some
some particular hypergraph maybe it's
absorbed and limited I don't know yes
I'm just trying to understand yeah yeah
incoming outgoing no no absorbed and
admitted this is this is actually
incoming outgoing is not bad because
that doesn't that is simply saying for
this event these are the incoming things
these are the outgoing things does
Jonathan have an opinion about this
I think that's too weak
um I agree maybe just created and
destroyed this is is on the other hand
too strong yeah but the fact that for
instance you can
um you can have outgoing tokens that
inhibit all subsequent events for a
particular computational scheme means
that you know just describing it with a
purely passive verb doesn't seem quite
right
hmm look I think this inhibitory thing
is a different overlay that I don't
think we should get ourselves too
confused by I think it really is a major
you know but but again I just like
before what I'm not what the point I'm
making is nothing to do with inhibition
I'm just using that as an illustrative
example
yeah
I have to say I I what say again what
you think is wrong with him coming and
up going what that Jonathan that is
basically intransitive
um I mean James I didn't really
understand your monologue I I may have
to ask you about that later but if if
we're using a passive verb like you know
red you're using passive terminology
like read write or incoming outgoing or
whatever
um then you know the so okay going back
to the example I gave right at the
beginning right you you've got some rule
that acts on
um you know
a K5 subgraph or something and you know
you've just applied an event that's just
that's gotten rid of the only K5 sub
graph that you had in your graph
rewriting system
that is a fairly destructive process
right it has a significant Upstream
effect on all subsequent uh event and
causal structure
and therefore using it using a just
saying that you know a particular
collection of tokens have been you know
uh were incoming or have been read or
something seems somehow too weak
but that's yeah
well I mean something comes in and it
doesn't go okay
I have to say from what I'm hearing
incoming outgoing is the least confusing
so far but I might be wrong but let's
keep going here for a second because
what we're seeing is
okay
okay Nick do you want to say
okay what on Earth is this tree position
why is there a tree I thought everything
was turned into high poetry
no it's a multiway tree
because your eyes
you're saying before equivalence before
equivalents somewhere up here the thing
was a genuine tree
right this this thing here was just a
tree yeah so everything that that is not
like that
oh I see there we see the the um the
actual the hypergraph version
everything that is not like that is not
like that because of canonicalization
were it not for canonicalization it
would all just be a tree and maybe the
from the outside of the universe
everything that happens in our universe
just treeing out
and everything else is being pulled
together by these canonicalization
functions
now is that all we need here we need the
evolution function that says how to
transform a state into multiple States
right that's what we have here
correct and then we need these these
canonicalization functions
equivalency functions correct
well I'm not sure whether it's something
else is needed depends on what you need
well I don't know you tell me I mean but
to generate the multi-way graph
okay what does token canonical function
it's only for the token when the graph
because now you
State the blue boxes is just the
individual hyper edges so it's just a
little different I couldn't name it the
same way
um sorry I don't understand this what
are you saying here
well token all it's doing is taking for
example well the evolution causal graph
or something like that and
decompose this state into the tokens
I mean because all everything is hyper
graphs it just decomposes it into hyper
edges
right and if you canonicalize each
individual hypergraph with its default
type like here it's a string
it's going to be just a character
I I'm a little confused I mean if we ask
for the token event graph one of the
things we can do in a token event graph
is to say that we have you know pairs of
things you know we say something like x
blank y blank goes to X Plus y x minus y
for example correct
yeah maybe tokenography is a bad
property name it should be
that glocal thing
I don't understand what does this do is
this going to do something reasonable
I don't think it's gonna work oh
but this should work right
because our standard token event graph
function does work in this case
right
yeah it works in this case but
okay but so this is just a bug or
there's something different
maybe it's a bug can you wrap one and
and one in additional list or something
but I'm not sure oh
that looks right
that looks right that that's taking
that's the sort of
scattering event
okay
by the way I mean this is a physics
question I don't know everybody
does this in fact generate the finding
diagrams of five fourth field Theory
anybody have an opinion Jonathan do you
have an opinion about that I think you
must do for a particular
you know if you have two incoming legs
this is combining these things in all
possible ways I think
which kind of means there should be a
formalism for working out you know
anyway never mind that was irrelevant
but I strongly wanted to comment on that
uh well I mean yes there is a formalism
yeah okay
this is a consequence of the fact that
string diagrams and Feynman diagrams are
equivalent for factorial field theories
and
um token uh well at least local
multi-way systems are string diagrams or
interconvertible string diagrams
let me understand that statement because
string diagram is also something we
really want to under okay but these are
not string diagrams so that true or
these must be very close to string
diagrams I mean a string diagram can
take
okay can somebody explain anybody know
how this works so we want to treat
tokens as some kind of types system
types in the string diagram and your
events are actual processes or boxes
yeah and all the edges are kind of wires
except the causal there because we just
doesn't mean anything in that string
diagrams no I understand string diagrams
don't have causal edges so this would be
a a
um this would be a States graph
but with this after the canonization of
each of the state
it's an evolution called graph
I don't understand you said it doesn't
have
but we have to break the things into
tokens right yeah the kind of local
story
right
so do we have a representation of that
that is essentially
anything that breaks into token 7 I only
made for the token and graph for now
that's the only thing that breaks things
into tokens okay but this could break
into tokens here
yeah so that's probably a good thing to
have
um well I'll call it states graph maybe
just token graph or something
yeah I think token graph would be a good
name for it
and then
but that's what's happening here if we
if we you know got rid of the events
this is that token graph correct
it's weird because string diagrams if
you
getting rid of
eventually getting rid of the boxes the
main thing yeah so that can't work so I
mean okay this probably is
um
well it's like I can I can I have it in
the quantum fabric for example we have a
if you
have a
circuit diagram with Gates representing
events you can make a tensor Network
when each event is a gate
right and you also can turn this tensor
Network and this
basically when each gate is some kind of
uh click
graph click so we only have tensor
indices
those would be represent those would be
like tokens
okay so those are names for the wires
you're saying tokens yeah open cell
names for the wires the system types
yes and how does that relate to string
diagrams again
I mean so are you saying this basically
is a string diagram well these are the
boxes and these are the names named
indices going into the boxes is that
right or am I confused
oh yeah basically it just may be string
diagram also especially shows the
ordering
of how those
wires are connected to the events which
one is the first one so on the second
but doesn't this show that too because
it has arrows well it's kind of
arbitrary
right you don't know by just graph
layout which one is the first one
why does it matter so so is there a
tensor representation of this of this
diagram here for the events here you can
basically what does the tensor
representation of a string diagram you
turn every event here into a tensor
where each incoming state is a like
growth
your row index and the output token
would represent the colon index
is that is that the analog of coherent
and contrivance yeah yeah is the same
way yeah yeah okay so you're saying that
this thing here could be written as a
product for tenses
where the knitting together by virtue of
these edges
so by the way that's that's a place
where it matters whether the aims how
the aims are named how the tokens are
named right because in this case
that too better not be the same as this
two here
no it would just mean if your equivalent
the damage just mean an additional
contraction
I agree but that contraction is not what
we actually want
for um I mean that contraction if we
were writing this as tensors this would
be i j k l
and it better not be the case that this
is i i j j
you see what I'm saying
yeah it actually is not the construction
in terms of string diagonals it's an
additional event that has an output
those
the same thing I see the point is what
you're saying is these are not the
hypergraph indices these are the payload
right we can see the hypergraph indices
there and that's just the payload
Jonathan sent through something here
this looks exciting
it's lovely he says well he says it's
lovely that this stuff just runs
okay
wow all right what is this
you know I love your stuff except you
have such a pre-election for these bold
face letters which seem to me to make it
more ugly than it needs to be anyway a
very minor point maybe at some moment we
should spend a few minutes of design
time on these but go ahead explain no no
I I wanted to get a concrete example of
some tensor networks
um and do the relationship to function
composition
can you explain here so f is that a
composition or is that something
different no that's the tensor is a
parallel is a parallel composition right
so these are
you know okay all right high level point
of course is that you so
single way computation produces a
category multi-computation produces a
monoidal category
um the bronchial graphs are the
Intensive products of tokens or states
that lie on a single time slice and then
the edges that relate them are tensor
products of the you know the
corresponding morphisms this is
demonstrating that explicitly for the
case of an abstract category right so so
f and g here are functions you could
think of them as being like Evolution
events x y z z are essentially like
tokens
so what are what are these different
things here I mean when you say G cross
F pair yeah so so so G tensor F it's
saying there are within the so that the
um the framework has a whole tensor you
know effectively has an internal tensor
algebra subsystem so it's showing within
this framework what are all equivalent
ways of representing that tensor product
it's D it's taking every morphism every
tensor product morphism in the monoidal
category and it's decomposing it so it's
saying so so F here is a function from X
to Y and G is a function from y to Z and
it's saying okay so there are three
different ways we can represent G tensor
F it's either you take y tensor X you
apply G tensor F and you get Z tensor y
or you apply or you take y tensor X you
apply G tense of the identity on X you
get Z tensor X then you apply the
identity on Z tensor F and you get Z
tensor Y and that's hold on hold on I'm
I'm I'm still deeply confused there are
certain set of relations here
mm-hmm
what's the actual input that you were
doing something to here
I mean there are relations that you're
applying but what
are these being relations applied to an
input
uh no so this is in a sense of
in a way you can think of this as being
relations applied to all possible inputs
because it's the it's the free the
strict monodial category that's freely
generated by that quiver
okay can you relate this
okay can you relate this to like this
this do you have an analog of this
diagram here in the category in this
categorical okay well I mean every
concrete quiver is a effectively a
global multi-way system
and so so then so there the events are
the are the boxes these the tokens are
the wires
um and then the you know the the tensor
product structure is the way you
construct branchial graphs
and what are the what are the triangles
those triangles are identities those are
identity morphisms so they're just like
boxes but they're boxes that just go
straight through yeah exactly so that
that's actually
um there's there are a few different
ways people have notated uh string
diagrams over the years I'm using the
one that's closest to Penrose graphical
notation okay uh so in graphical
notation that would be a that would be
an identity
and and so this here is a two to two
event yeah so it's that's a rank four
tensor with two contrary and two
covarian indices if you want to think
about that that way
just I'm sorry the tensor product your
statement that a branchial graph yeah
why isn't the whole graph here a tensor
product why are you saying only the
branchial graph is a tensor product
well so it's you
you can't take a tensor product of a of
a state and an event right
just as you know you if you think about
whatever ordinary tensor calculus you
can take tens of products of a you know
a helmet space with a Hilbert space or a
matrix with a or you know a linear
transformation with a linear
transformation you can't take a tensor
product of a Hilbert space with space
with a linear transformation
but my understanding is this is like a
tensor with indices ijkl yep exactly and
it is pluggable
or you're saying this has to be an X
that plugs into another thing that has
an x on it is that right
yeah I mean well you can see some
plugins I mean this is why I sent the
example right if you scroll down so
here's some non here's some slightly
more non-trivial Plumbing right so so
big F takes in an X tensor X now puts a
y tensor Y and Big G it takes a a white
engine Y and outputs a z tensor Z
um if I'm trying to understand this in
terms of transfer indices are these like
typed tensor indices or something of
type XYZ or something that is you know
in naive tensor indices this I would
assume would be you know f i j
K
if I'm understanding correctly
and this would be G
k
LM or something or am I wrong uh yeah in
in the sense that yes so the with the KK
representing the fact that these are the
the
function
thinking about thinking about tenses as
being a formalism for you know
multi-argument multi-value functions
that they're you know what your the the
KK is indicating that it has two values
but they're the same
yes
but now is it the case that if I want to
plug things onto the X here
that um uh
that that I can only plug an X onto an X
is that true
why am I confused there this is not a
dummy ax this is an actual X of some
kind in the sense of the function big F
will only evaluate if it's fed in X
tensor X
yeah whereas actually X it's not dummy X
it's the object X yep
right so
right but that's not like ordinary
tensors t i j k l it's like you can plug
the I into any index of any tensor the I
could contract against any index of any
tensor there's no type information about
the eye
well it's more like in an or with with
um with ordinary tensor calculus the
identity of the box would change if you
fed it a different thing
right is if you think about this again
if you think about it in the ordinary
tensor calculus case where you've got
you know these are Hilbert spaces and
linear Transformations then if you feed
it a diff you know if you take your um
your linear transformation you feed it a
different Vector space in this left hand
side of the tensor product or something
yeah then it's a different linear
transformation
I understand hey Nick how do I make this
work does this need this resource object
thing again
oh well let's hope
I tried it myself it worked without it
okay forget it
can you show this on your screen
it's a simple
tensor Network for
for this circuit when you have
and its index representation just to
make it a little bit clearer okay show
the circuit again for a second can you
show the circuit yeah
so I have H and one C naught we just
two input
two output tensor basically
what is the H doing for us here it's
just a it's the analog of one of it's a
one to one thing is that right
just taking one input wire and giving
out one output yeah right right
and this is like a representation of a
tensor Network when you only have an
indices
and when you have like
very high rank one you make a complete
graph out of it like like a click so
this is like a complete graph that
represents this four rank tensor
and all the indices are connected when
they're contracted together
so when you if you uneviate a circuit
you just contract all the corresponding
indices
oh
am I correctly understanding
Jonathan categories this Quantum thing
the The multi-way Inspired token event
graphs and so on these are all the same
is that right I mean these are all
basically interconvertible formalisms
that true statement
yeah
and what I mean so in a sense
that makes us want to design from a
language design point of view
wants us want to make I mean you know
it's just like we could have said oh
we've got algebraic expressions and
we've got graphics objects and we've got
this and we've got that but in fact we
can represent them all as tree
structured symbolic Expressions so I
guess what I'm looking for is the grand
unification between all these things and
maybe you guys have already figured this
out
but what is the kind of grand unified
you know just like
a notebook is an expression that is a
tree structured expression just like an
algebraic expression and so on
what is the common
representation that one day could be the
foundation for all of these
things which are ultimately equivalent
did that question make sense
yeah and I mean you know my view so like
what no I did Jonathan
assume I know nothing what what is your
view
well that I mean concrete categories are
the way to think about this right that
that's that's the reason why this do why
this correspondence exists
okay but explain maybe we should go back
to my screen for a second here and I'm
unfortunately I'm gonna have to leave
soon but but um uh
okay but but
okay
so
this is what okay this is an abstract
category so that that is um
um
uh
explain that statement I mean in other
words
I understand but what we're trying to do
is make a minimal
the thing is that somehow this looks
very declarative
which perhaps I don't know I mean do we
think this is there's a language design
to be made directly out of this or do we
think that this is a more mathematical
formalism that sits that potentially
sits on top of a length of a raw you
know symbolic expression language
designer it's like like you know you
could do language design in which
polynomials are a fundamental thing but
you wouldn't do that I mean you know we
you know the big mileage I mean look
historically boring historical points
before SMP basically all computer
algebra was done by people who said
we've got a representation for
polynomials we've got a representation
for you know vectors we've got a
representation for this and that okay
the big point
in SMP in particular was actually all of
these things can be represented as tree
structured symbolic Expressions so I
guess the question that I'm looking for
here is you know what is the analogous
and everything can be thought of as a
this and this is as easy to understand
as possible
and are you are you saying that
categories are the this in that sort of
sentence or are you saying categories
are a formalism that allows you that is
a you know a way to think about it but
is not it itself
foreign
how natural you think you know
sequential and parallel function
composition is as an idea I think it's
extremely natural but no that is a
natural idea but I don't think it's
represented in you know I think category
Theory
okay so again with the way Nick is doing
this
okay look we all agree that I think that
there is an evolution function and there
is equivalencing or canonicalization
functions
is that what you're also saying here
Jonathan
well yeah I mean like I said the the way
I've designed this is that so at least
in my formulation of this stuff which I
don't I mean Nick's code both for the
multi-way system framework and for the
quantum framework I think has diverged
from mine now quite significantly but
um
it's a local multi-way systems and
concrete Quivers are trivially
interconvertible in that system
um and both of them are interconvertible
with you know with well linear
transformations of Hilbert spaces which
is what the quantum stuff is about
all right we have a magnificent Grand
unification which is so close but not
quite there in my in my opinion I mean
it's like but what you're doing here
with this Jonathan with this category
Theory stuff which is great
is you know there's a whole literature
about category Theory and you know it's
like like you know this is the bridged
to all of that stuff I I'm not even I
should be clear I'm not even
particularly trying to
um you know to push category three I'm
just saying it's useful to actually have
unification between these functions yeah
yeah for sure but that's what I'm saying
is that I think okay you know again I am
pretty sure and we're so close here I'm
pretty sure there's a way to think about
all these things you know the thing that
is really clean about pre-structured
symbolic expressions and pattern
Transformations between them it's very
simple it's very easy to explain
and we're getting close to that with all
of this but we're not quite there yet as
all of us get confused about what's a
token and what's this and that and so on
right
sorry go ahead and then yeah but but
again okay I I'll make this point one
last time because it keeps getting
dismissed but I I do think it's an
important one that um
it's
the the way that tokens get composed and
ingested into events is kind of the core
of what makes multi-computation
complicated right so
um and in particular you know the thing
I like about the global multi-way
representation and probably which is
also true with the token event graph
representation as well is that in effect
all systems could you know that you okay
you've essentially got two tens of
product structures right you've got
tensor products of of tokens in space
and you've got tons of products of
tokens in in you know across branches
and uh the tensor product of tokens
across branches is necessarily
commutative and all multi-way systems
can be you know all computational
systems can be divided up into one of
two cases either the spatial composition
is uh is commutative as it is for
hypographs or it's not commutative as it
is for say uh Turing machines or
expressions
right
and that distinction essentially between
whether the whether the category is
monoidal or symmetric monoidal if you
want to phrase it that way
um is the reason I think for a lot of
these confusions about you know are
tokens really being destroyed or are
they just being referenced or whatever
um
because it because in that case it
matter you know the algebraic property
of how tokens compose in space actually
matters
right I mean look my suspicion would be
if there's a choice between oh it could
be commutative or it could not be that
the general case is going to be it's not
commutative
but that may be
you know because if you think about sort
of symbolic Transformations for symbolic
expressions and I really have to run in
a second here but if you think about
that
um the uh
um
um
you know it's it's very general there's
not there's no immediate kind of
you know there's no immediate oh and
this thing is commutative even though it
doesn't have to be type thing
okay I unfortunately have to go but we
need to continue this this is this is
great we're really getting somewhere in
my opinion despite
small technical glitches and so on
um
uh
good stuff all right I've got to run
sorry
see you all later bye